اعربت واشنطن عن قلقهما من مسمتاه تنام
شراكه الدفاعيه بين موسكو وطهران واكدتا
ان ايران تمثل الان الداعمه العسكري
الاكبر لروسيا ولا تزودها بالمسيرات
والصواريخ في مقابل الدعم العسكريا
وتقاليا روسي غير مسبوق لطهران بحسب وصفه
ماء وقد نفت ايران تزويدها روسيا
بالمسيرات واكدت ان اتهامها بذلك غير صحيح
ولا اسس له ولا ادله تؤكده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما مدى دقه حديث
واشنطن عن مستوى التعاون العسكري بين
موسكو وطهران وما هو الافق الذي يمكن ان
يذهب اليه ما هي الانعكاسات المحتمله لهذا
التعاون الروسي الايراني على الحرب في
اوكرانيا وعلى خريطه التحالفات الجيوب
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه في الشرق الاوسط
وما هي اوراق الغرب لمواجهه هذا التعاون
العسكري بين موسكو وطهران في ضوئي طبيعه
العلاقه التي تربطه التي تربطه بهما في
الوقت الراهن
[موسيقى]
مؤكدا لتصريحات مندوبه بلاد في مجلس الامن
وموافقا لما كشفته استخباراته بلاده
العسكريه قال جيمز وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني انما سماه الصفقات القذره بين
ايران وروسيا تهدد الامن العالمي اضاف
كليفر لان ايران تعتبر الان واحده من اكبر
دعم روسيا عسكريا واكد انها ارسلت اليها
مئات الطائرات المسيره الوزير البريطاني
قال ان روسيا تقدم في المقابل دعم
العسكريا وفنيا للنظام الايراني ما يزيد
من تهديده شركاء بريطانيا في المنطقه
ويشكل خطرا على الامن الدولي بحسب قوله
واكد ان لندن تتفق مع تقييم واشنطن بان
الدعم الايراني للجيش الروسي سوف يزداد في
الاشهر القادمه
تصريحات وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جاءت
غدات تحذيرا اطلقه منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه بمجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
جون كربي من خطوره مسماه الدعم الايراني
لروسيا في حربها على اوكرانيا وقال كريبي
ان العلاقه بين موسكو وطهران تتحول نحو
شراكه دفاعيه كامله تشمل تبادل الاسلحه
والخبره العسكريه بين الطرفين اضاف ان
واشنطن تبحث خيار جمع دول عديده لمناقشه
التعاون العسكري الروسي الايراني وانها
ستستخدم كل الادوات لعرقلتي هذه الشركه
واوضح قربي ان ايران اكبر داعما عسكريا
لروسيا وانها نقلت منذ اغسطس اب الماضي
مئات المسيارات الى موسكو وقال ان هناك
تقارير تشير الى ان موسكو وطهران تدرسان
ان شاء الله خط انتاجا مشتركا لطائرات
مسيره الفتاكه وفقا لصحيفه واشنطن بوست
الامريكي فان تقييمه واشنطن للتعاون
الروسي الايراني يستند لتقارير
استخباراتيه وتقارير امريكيه السابقه عن
بيع مئات الطائرات الايرانيه المسيره التي
تستخدمها روسيا حاليا لمهاجمه البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه الاخرانيه
اما ايران فقد نفذ عبر وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه ذلك مشيره الى ان اتهامها
بتزويد روسيا بالمسيرات غير صحيح ولا اسس
له ولا ادله تؤكده
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من طهران الدكتور
عماد رئيس نقابه مراكز الابحاث والدراسات
في ايران من فرجينيا معنى الدكتور
السابق لوزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ومن عمان
معانا اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
والعسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بكم جميعا
سنبدا معك دكتور عماد كيف تتعامل طهران مع
الحديث الامريكي عن شراك استراتيجيه
ديفاعيه كامله
تطور بين ايران
تحياتي لك ال سي للضيوف العزاء والمشاهدين
الكرام في الواقع ليس هناك من شيء جديد
يقوم الامريكان بالطرحه هناك
شرك
وتعاون عسكري ايراني روسي موجود منذ بضعه
سنوات هذا
التعويرات السنوات حتى اذا ما اردنا ان
نقول وطبعا بعض الضغوط الامريكيه
على ايران وروسيا والصين التعاون
العسكري بين هذه الدول زاد بشكل كبير جدا
يعني بعث هناك
مواجهه استراتيجيه او اذا ما اردنا ان
نقول لا نوع من التحالف الاستراتيجي بين
هذه الدول لمواجهه الضغوط الامريكيه
والتهديدات الامريكيه والغربيه عليهم ااه
السبب في الوصول الى هذا الحال هو
التصرفات الامريكيه والاوروبيه تجاه ايران
وروس والصين اذا ما اردنا ان نقول هذا
اولا ثانيا همم ما يحدث اليوم سببه انا
اضعه في سياق النا الدول الغربيه اليوم
تريد العوده الى المفاوضات النوويه هي
اوراقها ضعيفه في هذه المفاوضات ولهذا
السبب تحاول بشطه طرق ان تقوي اوراقها قبل
بدء جوله جديده من المفاوضات بين اجانبين
يعني انت تقول ان هذا
التحالف ليس جديدا ولكنه يبدو انه يتطور
ولهذا حذير لدى دول الغربيه خصوصا بعد
الحرب على اوكرانيا
عمليا هذا التحالف موجود ليس مرتبطا اصلا
ابدا بموضوع اوكرانيا يعني بدا يعني
المشاريع العسكريه الموجوده بين ايران
وروسيا عمليا هي طويله الامد وليست قصيره
الامد هناك
اتفاقيه التعاون استراتيجي بين ايران
وروسيا مدتها 20 عاما وهي تم التوقيع
عليها قبل همم يعني تمديدها لمده 20 عاما
عمليا تم توقيعها منذ 21 عاما
واليوم همم بما ان هناك
حربا في اوكرانيا لن تقوم ايران بوقف
تعاونها مع روسيا بسبب الحوادث او بسبب ما
تطالب به الدول الغربيه
الولايات المتحده والدول الغربيه ان كل
ضغوطها على همم موسكو وعلى همم طهران
ستؤدي الى هكذا تقارب في ظل اصلا التعاون
القائم بينهما
الى التعاون ولكن هذا ليس السبب الرئيسي
لماذا نرى واشنطن ودول المسؤوله تضغط على
روسيا وايران السبب هو انها دول مارقه
خارج القانون في روسيا اطلقت عمليه اشتياح
غير مشروع علي دوله مجاوره ايران تقتلوا
متظاهرها في الشارع الذين يطالبون
بالحريه من اجل عدم وضع غطاء للراس ايران
ايضا تبني
سبونج بوب
تضغط عليهما وهذا ما ادى الى تعاونيهما
بطريقه مكثفه اكثر
الضيف الكريم محيق هذه العلاقه وهذا
التعاون قديم ولكنه تعمق في الاسابيع
الاخيره التيما مع توفير ايران هذه
المسيرات التي تستخدمها روسيا لتدمير هنا
تحتيه
المدنيه في اوكرانيا وبتالي تتعاون ايران
مع روسيا في محاوله
لتجويعي الشعب الاوكراني وحتى الحمل على
حمله على الموت بارده
والغرب عموما من هذا التقارب باعتقادك
كلاسيه ما في هذه المرحله
يعني لو سمحتي لي في البدايه لا اتوقع ان
هناك شراكه استراتيجيه ولا تحالف لا يزال
الامر دون ذلك بدايه التعاون والتعامل
بدات في مع تفكك الاتحاد السوفيتي ومره في
فترات صعود وهبوط وكان هناك شيء من عدم
الثقه المتبادله بسبب الطموحات الجيو
سياسيه لكل الدولتين وبسبب ترسبات حرب
1813 الى
وبالتالي كان هناك حذر من كلا الجانبين
ولكن بدات الظروف تغيرها التغيرات التي
تحدث في المحيط الاقليمي والدولي تملي على
كلا دولتين ان يتقاربا وكمال قال ضيفك من
ايران هناك اتفاقيه يتعاون مشترك مده 10
سنوات تمدد تلقائيا خمس سنوات اذا لم يكن
هناك اعتراض خلال الاخيره تم وفي زمن
الرئيس خاتمي تم تحديث في زمن الرئيس
ابراهيم رئيسي وتحولت الى اتفاقيه عشرين
عام تغطي الابعاد السياسيه الاقتصاديه
التقنيه العسكريه الامنيه لماذا لانه بعد
وصول الرئيس بوتن في ولايته الثالثه
حاول ان يعيد كم موضع روسيا على الخارطه
العالميه في وسط اسيا في القفقاس في الشرق
الاوسط وهنا كان لابد له ان يجد من يتبادل
معه ويتعاون فكانت
ايران ثم جاءت الان هناك عاملين اساسيين
جاءت الحجم السوريه
والتنسيق الروسي
الايراني وذهاب قاسم سليماني اكثر من مره
لتدخل روسي
بتناغم ايراني ثم جاءت الحرب الاوكرانيه
هذه التغيرات املت على كل الطرفين
هذا التعاون العسكري بين الجانبين على
صعيد المسيارات على صعيد الصواريخ على
الصعيد الطائرات المقاتله على الصعيد
الاسلحه الدفاعيه بحسبتهامات الغربيه كل
ذلك كيف من شانه ان يؤثر على ما يحدث في
اوكرانيا وابعد من اوكرانيا ايضا
يعني هو يؤثر على منطقه الشرق الاوسط
بسبب ما ستقدمه روسيا من
مساعدات في التقنيه العسكريه والتقني
الفضائيه وفي عمليات تطوير الاسلحه وتزويد
الاسلحه الان الطيارين الايرانيين يتدربوا
في روسيا على طائره سوخوي 35 هناك تزويدها
بصواريخ اس 300 تزويدها بالدبابات تي 72
تزويدها بعربات قتاليه همم
اطلاق القمر الصناعي خيام واحد وهناك
تعاون مشترك في التقنيه الفضائيه لانتاج
خيام اثنين ثلاثه اربعه وبالتالي هذا
التعاون سيلقي بظلاله على منطقه الشرق
الاوسط بما تتلقاه ايران وسيلقي بظلال في
جمله على على ما يجري في اوكرانيا من خلال
التزويد بطائرات شاهد او طائ اخرى او
صواريخ روسيا تعاني من نقص في الصواريخ
ومن نقص في الطائرات المسيره وبالتالي
ستقدم خدمات للجانب الايراني مقابل خصوصا
على هذه الصوره
ما الذي يمكن ان ينتج عن هذه الاتهامات
الغربيه
فقط
موضوع ان الاتفاقيه بين ايران وروسيا
وقاعها السيد همم
رفصا جاني المرحوم رخصا جاني لمده 20 عاما
وتمديدها همم في زياره الرئيس الرئيس لمده
20 عاما همم اخرى قبل همم الحرب
الاوكرانيه اما بالنسبه
لموضوع التعاون الايراني الروسي هذا
التعاون هو سائر الى الزياده يعني هو
يزداد كل يوم بعد يوم نظرا لان العلاقات
الدوليه اساسها هي المصالح المشتركه اليوم
المصالح المشتركه الايرانيه الروسيه تقضي
به الوقوف امام همم
امام محاوله النيته التمدد نحو الشرق
بالطبع هذا رايناه في سوريا همم اما في اي
جبهه اخرى يريد تريد الناتو وهذا قال له
المرشد بنفسه يعني هذا ليس همم تحليلا
عمليه تريد ان تحققه ايران من هذا من هذا
من هذه الشراكه دكتور عماد ولكن انا اسالك
عن عن كيفيه التعامل المسؤولين في ايران
مع التهديدات وما يمكن ان ينتج عنها تجاه
ايران بالنسبه للمسؤولين الايرانيين ما
الذي يمكن ان ينتج عما يهدد به الغرب
نعم اليوم الموضوع الاساسي هو انه كان
متفقا منذ مارس الماضي انت تكون هناك
المفاوضات والتوقيع على الاتفاقيه في فينا
بعد بعد الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه
للاسف الطرف الغربي الولايات المتحده
تعللت في هذا الموضوع وطبعا التهديدات اذا
ما ازدادت على ايران ممكن ان تغير ايران
موقفها في التعاون او عدم التعاون يعني كل
هذا اليوم مرهون ب ااا رفع العقوبات عن
ايران
بالنوع التعاون الغربي مع ايران انا اريد
ان اضعها في هذا السياق الاتجاه العام في
ايران
للسياسه الايرانيه عموما هو اول همم او
يعني المدراء الايرانيون عموما هم لديهم
اتجاهات غربيه ليس ل اتجاه الشرقي ولكن
الحكومه الايرانيه الجديده بعد فشل كل
المحاولات لحل الخلافات مع الغرب اتجهت
نحو الشرق وكل ما يزيد الامريكيون
والغربيون من
ضغوطهم على ايران او لا ينفذ تعهداتهم
تجاه ايران سوف تزداد العلاقات الايرانيه
مع روسيا والصين قوه في شط المجلات
من الولايات المتحده سيد ماثيو اذا
الموضوع يعني يبدو سيف ذو حدين تزداد
الضغوط على هذه الدول تزداد الضغوط على
ايران من جهه وعلى روسيا من جهه اخرى ولكن
يزداد التقارب بينهما هل هذه التهديدات
التي
ساقتها اليوم الولايات المتحده بان واشنط
تبحث خيار جمع دول عديده لمناقشه هذا
التعاون وتستخدم كل الادوات لعرقلته هل هي
كافيه لوقف هذا تقارب
ثانكيو
اذا نظرنا على من هذا العالم ينقسم الى
ثلاثه قتل الولايات المتحده اخرى ودول
المسؤوله مثل
الانظمه الملكيه الحاكمه في الخليج ثانيا
لدينا
على الايرانيه
حركه عدم الانحياز الهند اندونيسيا ودول
الاخرى لا تريد ان تاخذ جانبا ضد الاخر
اعتقد ان ايران
منذ اشهر كان هناك كثيرون في اوروبا في
اداره
وتعاون مع ايران كانوا يعملوا توصل اتفاق
نووي ولكن الان بعد ان بدات ايران بقتل
شعبها من خلال التصدي العنيف لهذه
التظاهرات وهي وروسي ما في حربها شعواء ضد
اوكرانيا ايران تو شوهوا سمعه وصورتها في
الاسره الدوليه راينا حزمه جديده ضد من
العقوبات عفوا ضد دائره وشركات وكذلك ضد
روسيا اعتقد ان هذا في او الى تزايد
وبالتالي ايران سوف تزداد عزالتها برايه
هذه اعلن القلق عن القلق الامريكي من هذا
التقارب الروسيه الايراني حتى اعلن عن
حزمه دعم عسكري جديده لاوكرانيا باعتقادك
همم كيف سينعكس همم ستنعكس هذه الاتهامات
على مسار هذه الحرب
يعني الان هناك يعني التقارير الوارده من
الشيعي ومختلف الوكالات الامنيه
البريطانيه الالمانيه الامريكيه تشير الى
احتماليه
تزايد كميات الاسلحه التي ستصل تحديدا
الطائرات المسيره وان كان بيقين اقل فيما
يتعلق بالمنظومات الصاروخيه لانها قد تسبب
اشكاليه اخرى وتعقيدات اضافيه الان عندما
نتحدث عن تخصيص 275 مليون دولار كمساعدات
امريكيه تم ال- ال- الافصاح عنها يوم امس
وتضمنت همم مولدات كهرباء تضمنت اسلحه
مخصصه لمواجهه مسيرات همم صواريخ مارس
قذائف
رقم يعني غير همم
بعشرات الالاف من قذائف 155 عاوز زر هذا
هو ياتي في اطار ادامه القدره الاوكرانيه
على الاستمرار في التصعيد خاصه اذا اعتمد
تصريح تصريحات الرئيس بوتن وبقيه اركان
القياده الروسيه ان الحرب قد تستمر حتى
نهايه 2025 سواء كان هناك مساهمه ايرانيه
او توقفت المساهمه سيل الامدادات والجسر
الجوي سيبقى مستمرا ولكن زياده المساهم
الايراني في الدعم العسكري ستنعكس ايجابا
بزياده الامدادات المقدمه الى الجانب
الاخراني
من عمان وشكرا للدكتور ماثيوبينج المستشار
السابق بوزاره الدفاع الامريكيه من
فرجينيا والدكتور عماد رئيس نقابه
ضيفنا من طهران
الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]